ja und das ist nicht so einfach heute
hier nach diesen nach diesen anderen
themen am anfang zu den übergang zu
schaffen aber ich mache es trotzdem mal
ja ich habe mich heute auf gericht über
karl lauterbach und sein
gesundheitsminister den lauterbach würde
jetzt millionen deutschen eine vierte
impfung verabreichen also allen den über
60 weil er sagt das hilft super gegen
korona und das wird neueste studien aus
israel belegen aus israel wer kann dem
noch widersprechen gott sei dank gibt es
dass sie also im internet und guckt man
sich das mal etwas genauer an dann sieht
man dass diese studien auch aus israel
sehr scharf kritisiert werden weil die
sagen das hilft gar nicht gegen die
korona infektion und auch nicht gegen
eine omikron infektion auch nicht bei
denen die über 60 sind und die new york
times ja eine der angesehensten
zeitungen der welt hat heute ebenfalls
darauf hingewiesen dass es gerade bei
dieser israelischen studie die von karl
lauterbach angebracht wird und
hervorgehoben wird schwere methodische
fehler gibt auch das ist nachzulesen nun
ist er nicht ungewöhnlich dass es bei
verschiedenen wissenschaftlichen studien
auf verschiedene meinungen gibt auch bei
wissenschaftlern
ungewöhnlich ist es aber wenn der
minister der sich um unsere gesundheit
kümmern soll die die kritik an seinen
thesen gar nicht zulässt sie auch nicht
erwähnt oder wenn überhaupt in abrede
stellt so wie er es gemacht hat mit
einem wissenschaftler der ehe von bild
zitiert worden dies so gesagt hat nur
durst ist ja so wie der song pauli der
wissenschaft aber mein freund christian
drosten das ist der fc bayern
wahrscheinlich hat er nicht gewusst des
fc st pauli baldauf steigt in die erste
liga wahrscheinlich und das dem verein
ganz viele herzen
zugewendet sind ich finde das was karl
lauterbach mittlerweile zeigt mit seiner
ausgrenzung von andersdenkenden ist eine
beispiellose arroganz es ist die
arroganz eines mittlerweile völlig wirr
wirkenden ministers der im lichte des
eigenen scheinwerferlichts der tv
studios immer wieder neue ideen sucht um
in diesen talkshows zu bestehen die aber
nichts mit der realität zu tun haben das
schlimme ist aber karl lauterbach ist
kein einfacher wird kopf er ist ein
minister wirkt und ich finde wirre
menschen sollten nicht an der spitze von
ministerien stehen
ich finde wir sollten mehr gelassenheit
haben vor allen dingen deshalb weil
diese gar nicht
dass beide über erich hackl das aber
diese regierung hat einen großen schritt
gemacht indem das infektionsschutzgesetz
novelliert wurde in dem wir jetzt
zurückfinden zur normalität in dem jetzt
ab dem 12 april auch die
übergangsfristen die gesetzt wurden
auslaufen und wir damit tatsächlich
wieder die normalität stück für stück in
verantwortung zurück bekommen sagen sie
doch dass ich da ist weiblich stehe ich
ihnen auch zu das ist die fdp da kann
man sagen bravo die das vorangetrieben
hat das können sie sich mit ihrer partei
auf die fahne schreiben aber das hat
auch nichts zu tun mit dem
verantwortlichen wirken von der
lauterbacher die impfpflicht für uns
alle noch immer durchsetzen will also
ich sage wer normalität will der sollte
sich besser impfen und das kann jeder
für sich selbst entscheiden auch das ist
im übrigen ergebnis der politischen
debatte im deutschen bundestag
dass wir keine impfpflicht im augenblick
hier haben sie müssen nicht so
zurückkommt ist sagen dass daher ihr
verdienst und ja ich will ja nur sagen
jetzt immer auf dem
bundesgesundheitsminister umzupolen
kammer machen ich sage nur wir sollten
uns lieber mit der frage
auseinandersetzen wie bereiten für uns
auf den herbst vor dazu will ich
beiträge hören und wenn eine vierte
rundfunk sie einmal kurz nachher in
alles geben aber dafür einen
gesundheitsminister der kompetent ist
der das beste für dieses land fällt und
sie würden sagen gut dass herr minister
ist ich glaube dass wir im sich eine
gute regierung haben die
wir reden nicht über die fdp wir reden
nicht die regierung störte alarmismus
von herrn lauterbach
wer stört mich aber die frage ob wir
jetzt eine vierte impfung brauchen die
einen selbst schützt
und welchen beitrag sie leisten kann die
müssen wir doch offen diskutieren gerade
wenn wir mal in diesem land vor der
welle sein wollen und nicht hinter der
welle und da muss man natürlich auch
andere studien zu lassen da gebe ich
ihnen völlig recht dass ein punkt wo den
recht gebe ich glaube aber dennoch
sollten wir jetzt mal anerkennen dass
wir den weg in die normalität
zurückfinden und weniger alarmismus man
aber dennoch erscheint muss ich als
bürger sagen genau wie nähen es gesagt
hat man verliert trotzdem die das
vertrauen in die regierung vor allem
auch das vertrauen in herrn lauterbach
wenn jede woche etwas neues gesagt wird
wenn sie eine gewisse konsequenz auch da
ist in dem was gesagt wird in dem was
gefordert wird in dem was empfohlen wird
dann verliert man das vertrauen und dann
fragt man sich schon okay was kann man
jetzt glauben was kann man nicht glauben
und was ist richtig und was ist nicht
richtig kennt jetzt einfach sein höheren
7 nicht mehr zu erwarten
dass wir die beschlüsse der regierung
die abgewogen aus stimmen der spd der
grünen und der fdp
abgestimmt ein lösungsvorschlag in
ordnung sind auf jeden fall schon mal
der diplomat der runde den titel
vielleicht ihn jetzt aber jetzt kommen
wir doch mal zu herrn bosbach und
schauen mal ob herr bosbach aus
diplomatischer lauterbach ist
nein kann ich nicht sein es tut mir
schon fast leid dass ich das sagen muss
ich kann ihn mittlerweile auch nicht
mehr ernst nehmen er ist ja einige
monate gut über die runden gekommen und
mit dem standard vokabular neueste
studien aus harvard exzellente fachleute
wenn ich alle persönlich und er hat dann
den eindruck einer überragenden
kompetenz vermittelt und da waren ja
viele froh endlich einer der nicht nur
gesundheitspolitik macht sondern der
auch mediziner ist und der richtig
ahnung vom thema hat klammer auf im
gegensatz zum damaligen amtsinhaber jens
spahn klammer zu dann gab es für mich
ein ein wirkliches erlebnis nämlich karl
lauterbach bekam im zdf morgenmagazin
aber im leben nicht mitgerechnet ein
paar kritische fragen gestellt nämlich
aber nicht zu oft an am ismus verbreiten
würde daraufhin lauterbach das war so
vor 23 monaten
das ist die kampagne der bild zeitung
daraufhin habe ich mir mein tempel fisch
nacht und habe nur zwei wörter
lauterbach warnt und am klopfte es an
allem an ich habe fast ein kabelbrand
bekommen denn es gibt 50 60 fälle vor
denen lauterbach gewarnt hat dann haben
wir etwas anderes gemacht ich hab mal
die diagnose und prognose von klaus
stöhr von hendrik strikt daneben gelegt
die waren viel genauer als das was uns
karl lauterbach erzählte aber eins
wackler lädst du lauterbach in eine
sendung einem hast du am nächsten tag
eine fette schlagzeile weil er mit
sicherheit wieder vor irgendetwas fernen
wird dann hat er auch am rande oster
vergangenen jahres die spanischen ärzte
und virologen mein mann meine eben für
komplett sachkundig erklärt die zahl
würde er überhaupt nicht glauben da
würde nur beschummelt warum ist
gesundheitsminister geworden weil er zu
den bekanntesten populärsten politik und
gehört das stimmt weil ihn sozusagen das
votum der fernsehzuschauer ins
gesundheitsministerium getragen hat es
hatte schon seinen grund warum kann laut
dabei nie ein regierungsamt inne hatte
und wenn er meint dass er jetzt die
lösung ich bin einer der kandidaten
nicht nur weil ich über 60 bin sondern
wenige tag werde ich als die passion
lieber karl lauterbach nach zwei jahren
bin ich erkrankt einen monat nach meiner
vierten impfung kann man ja ich bin ich
bin viermal geben so kann man natürlich
sagen ja es war kein schwerer verlauf
was auch stimmt klammer auf gottseidank
klammer zu aber so zu tun
ich habe immer impfung verstandene
sterile immunität wenn du dich dagegen
impfen lässt ein ganz so nicht mehr
daran erkannt jedenfalls im regelfall
das stimmt schon lange nicht
herr bosbach ich glaube sie haben also
alle sitzen jetzt bestimmt der scheine
wahrscheinlich auch schon ins lager ich
glaub darunter geweckt von lars
lagerbäck ich glaube darüber dass airbus
back meine these einfach nur noch einmal
unterstrichen hat wenn normalität will
sollte sich besser impfen ganz einfach
die
hat er noch unterstrichen indem er
gesagt hat er hat melden verlangte
schaar ja recht ob ich im kampf gegen
das wenn ein gegner eines impfzwang is
ja ja das teile ich das vorher
lauterbach teilen sie auch was ja
bosbach gesagt hat den impfzwang
und wir sind natürlich so weit dass wir
jetzt mittlerweile uns einmal
auseinandersetzen müssen mit der drosten
regel die ja sagt am besten schütze ich
mich wenn nach drei mal geimpft und drei
mal infiziert am besten schwer dann bin
ich wahrscheinlich so drosten
originalton für mehrere jahre gut
geschützt was ist jetzt mit der vierten
impfungen bedeutet ob ich mich jetzt
auch noch danach nach osten ein viertes
mal infizieren muss auch am besten am
besten schwer um dann für mehrere jahre
geschützt zu sein weiß ich nicht ich
kann nur sagen
lauterbach und sein haus sollte sich mal
intensiv auseinandersetzen mit den
kritischen studien sie sollten den mut
haben diese kritischen studien auch zu
der vierten impfung zu besprechen zu
bewerten und die menschen zu sagen was
es damit auf sich hat denn in diesen new
york times ist ja auch jetzt nicht sein
pauli nachrichten um man mit lauterbach
zu sprechen der solche kritischen
studien er immer nur verunglimpft dann
auch das steht ganz klar drin dass die
über 60 in der regel nichts davon haben
und ich finde es einfach unredlich wenn
man solche kritik ausblendet sie wie den
virologen der wie gesagt von bild.de
zitiert worden ist verächtlich macht nur
weil ihm nur weil einem die meinung
nicht passt das ist kann man vielleicht
machen als abgeordneter in talkshows
aber nicht mehr als minister